bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 cultura numéro
entièrement consacré à la programmation
des salles saint-quentinoise pour la
saison 2017-2018 et on débute avec la
première programmation celle de la scène
nationale
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
propose près de 70 spectacles à
découvrir du théâtre du cirque de la
danse et de la musique et une saison
surtout tournés vers l'ouverture
écoutez les précisions de lionel max et
à son directeur
quand on parle d'ouverture c'est
différent en différents niveaux c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on regarde la saison
dans son ensemble il ya à peu près 50%
de la saison qui est composé de
spectacles jeune public ou de spectacles
dit kolon labellise à voir en famille
parce que tout simplement considère que
la fréquentation des oeuvres doit se
faire dès le plus jeune âge et on se
rend compte que des personnes qui ont 20
25 ans qui vont au théâtre c'est parce
qu'elles ont fréquenté l'été est souvent
dans le cadre dans le cadre familial
donc ça c'est un point très important et
puis en ce qui concerne la saison jeune
public plus de la moitié bien plus de la
moitié des spectacles jeune public des
représentations sont jouées en soirée
donc spectacles familiaux ça veut dire
que les parents peuvent amener dans son
front spectacle spectacle jeune public
en soirée ça veut dire que des enfants
peuvent amener leurs parents au
spectacle et le théâtre national
relancer rencontré une cité cette
deuxième édition se déroulera du 17 au
25 mars une semaine de liens entre l'art
et la science autour d'une thématique
humain 1 demain
le premier rendez vous sans objet de la
compagnie 111 est un face à face entre
êtres humains et robots regarder
[Musique]
et
du côté de la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt la saison est placée sous le
signe de la création de la liberté et de
l'émancipation
son directeur nous en dit un peu plus la
ferme de bel ébat apporté un soutien
important à la création à des artistes
émergents ou plus confirmés sur sur 48
spectacle c'est une vingtaine de
créations dont 8 qui ont lieu sur place
et effectivement je crois que c'est très
important aujourd'hui que les théâtres
qu'il s'agisse de celles nationales ou
de tête municipaux accorde une grande
confiance aux artistes et les
accompagnent on vit une période qui
n'est pas forcément facile pour les
artistes
et voilà c'est important que des
théâtres comme l'assaut national de
saint quentin en yvelines où la ferme de
bel ébat reste présente à leurs côtés
pour les accompagner dans leur processus
de création
cette saison débute dès le 9 septembre
avec ses contes de praliné gay-para dans
sa caravane dans cette salle aussi de
nombreux genres artistiques à découvrir
et notamment une comédie musicale médina
mary cas une enquête policière dans une
ville imaginaire
aujourd'hui
j'ai tué le
un homme que je ne les
aussi bien que s'il avait des démons
propre frère
[Musique]
on reste à guyancourt mais on parle
musique à présent la batterie propose à
nouveau une saison éclectique du reggae
du jazz du classique mais aussi du raf
le 9 décembre ces mêmes trois concerts
en vain coyotes et celui en courtoisie
et les sages poètes de la rue
regardez du tri j'en ai assez entendu
maintenant je dit basta
évidemment c'est juste énervant mais tu
me force à que le tir telle accra a su
le détergent donc s'il vous plaît que
quelques à haute de ma vue tous et
castrats les mecs n'ont kookaboora juin
qui vont des copies quand il ne s'agit
que de tracer sa route faisait sa tête
si je veux lutter pour ma survie comme
le dernier des mamours je vais te
blesser couvrir de partout comme des
sandales m
je suis dans les clashs de cliquer
jumeaux balance des bombes et jeu
dès que tu n'es tu mets un pied dans la
tombe et des soirées toujours en deux
temps puisqu'il ya toujours une première
partie d'artistes en devenir
parmi les dates à retenir le 14 octobre
avec une firme abb et akalé wubé germa
l'idée c'est un vieux monsieur qui a
plus de 70 ans un éthiopien qui a fait
une pause pendant 25 ans et c'est
francis falceto qui fait les
compilations ethiopiques qui est allé le
récupérer entre guillemets pour le
persuader de remonter sur scène
et donc il nous fera le l'honneur de
venir jouer dans l'auditorium on va
sortir le grand piano et puis et puis
derrière donc le second pack alegre
betclic qui a vraiment un groupe très
très très très important très longtemps
donc je pense que les gens vont
rapidement se mettre debout à
l'auditorium en prend maintenant la
direction de montigny le bretonneux une
saison qui démarrera sur de l'humour le
30 septembre à canon manaf d'autres
têtes d'affiché a cité vincent michelot
alex loth françois xavier demaison donc
en franck dubosc impossible de tout
citer mais des spectacles plus
intimistes sont aussi à découvrir comme
les chatouilles interprété par andrea
bespin l'histoire d'une jeune danseuse
dont l'enfance a été volé
tu te fais tu es fragile encore blue
tilt matin dans tes bras de creton que
te vient pas trop invisible caché
derrière tous et une guigne matin
moment là
[Musique]
non
e
m
un autre spectacle aux thèmes forts à
découvrir brasseurs et les enfants du
paradis mais je laisse jean christophe
archambault vous le présenter j'ai
découvert cette pièce à l'automne
dernier g j'y suis allée comme ça en
sachant pas très bien ce qu'est l'être
ce projet là et j'étais très étonnée
d'abord par le la performance
d'alexandre brasse où donc la rencontre
de génération
comme vous l'avez dit fils petit fils
etc et puis le sujet quand même une
espèce d'hommage comme ça son grand père
qui a été commis dans ce film est donc
c'est un seul en scène aussi qui m'a
vraiment impressionné puisqu'il incarne
tous les tous les personnages qui ont
fait l'histoire de ce film en partie de
notre patrimoine donc carnet réalisateur
trauner l'éducateur cosma la musique et
il raconte un peu tout ce qui s'est
passé quand ils étaient tous réunis dans
ce qu'ils ont de prendre ans pendant
l'occupation
avec toutes les questions que cela
pouvait poser à réty aussi était dans le
film les gens étaient plus ou moins dans
des situations différentes par rapport à
cette situation particulière et donc ils
l'enjeu et qui est réussie et très
intéressant de faire revivre tout ça est
sûre sur un sujet qui reste d'actualité
aujourd'hui comment on se positionne
quand on fait du spectacle
quand on crée quelque chose quand on se
rencontre avec la diversité des uns et
des autres tu es grand nombre c'est du
côté de plaisir michel drucker vous nos
salles ou encore clémentine célarié mais
aussi le spectacle tout public vincent
les objectifs fixés par la ville par la
madame le maire sont très claires c'est
saison éclectique il en faut pour tout
le monde
détail affichent des spectacles un peu
plus confidentielle mais plus
intéressant peut-être parfois
artistiquement ou encore qu'ils ont tous
à l'intérieur testing bien sûr c'est pas
bien c'est pas parce que 10 c'est le ta
fiche que c'est pas intéressant mais
parfois des choses un peu plus voilà où
on en a créé on les glisse
voilà où non aux et la découverte on va
dire nous on appelait ça osella
découvert pas mal de spectacles
d'avignon la vigne on s'est vraiment
fait le vivier c'est le vivier elle
raconte la génèse de cyrano de bergerac
et obtenu cinq molière la pièce edmond
sera sur la scène du théâtre espace
coluche le 18 janvier nous sommes à
paris en décembre 1895 je n'ai rien
écrire
sans qu'on puisse trouver un sujet en
dosage seamine - provincial au de
bergerac
dieu est avec avec nîmes a commandé une
pièce en trois actes de mm
mais mieux connaître sauf que je
n'aurais pas écrit une ligne edmond
personne ne te connais je n'avais que
des fours et coquelin commande une pièce
champagne on ne peut pas manquer cyrano
en trois semaines molière monté d'heure
du pur bijou attrape la saison débute le
30 septembre prochain mais le nom de
l'artiste n'est pas encore connue et
cette saison encore la merise propose
une programmation très culture une benne
urbaine par dont l'une des dates clés le
21 octobre
je connais sa famille elle connaît la
sienne dans les moments durs elle
partage sa peine mais pas d'inquiétude
fait sa première et dernière
accroche toi le bonheur car elle
[Musique]
la famille au complet bonheur
je m'en moque
[Musique]
de la culture urbaine mais pas seulement
la salle propose aussi du théâtre comme
l'une des esclaves le 12 octobre
regardez c'est un marivaux je sais pas
si les gens connaissent un peu
l'histoire donc un simple la roue qui
tourne le monde des esclaves sont les
esclaves illégal n 2 les ménez et puis
debate esclaves voilà donc chacun son
tour et puis voilà c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est la mise en pièces qu
autour d'un autour d'un cube ou des
personnages sortent et rentrent de ce
cube et interviennent au fur et à mesure
sur cette île et chacun sa place
et puis on voit vite souvent que ben
finalement les anciens tortionnaires ma
clément deviennent vite à se prendre à
leur propre jeu
oh là là oui oui c'est le premier rendez
vous de la saison pour coignières le 19
septembre le théâtre
alphonse daudet présente cette année
encore de nombreux genres hearts le
théâtre il ya moi il ya beaucoup de
compagnies régionales puisque je
travaille beaucoup avec des compagnies
professionnelles régionales comme par
exemple le théâtre des pays de la loire
donc il n'y a pas de tête d'affiche
parce que les gens viennent voir at-elle
et c'est pas le but le but pour moi
c'est de voir de découvrir l'oeuvre et
puis la mise en scène et donc il ya par
exemple la sphère de la rue de lourcine
de labiche par le théâtre des pays de la
loire
il ya aussi le cas martin pigeon c'est
un c'est un espèce de vaudeville les
théâtres parisiens de théâtre donc mais
aussi de la danse le rendez vous fort
c'est celui d'armstrong bâle est le 14
novembre
et la dernière programmation à laquelle
nous allons nous intéresser c'est celle
de saint cyr l'école la colonne début de
sa saison en humour avec un one man show
mais c'est là aussi l'éclectisme qui la
caractérise écoute
nous choisissons à saint cyr d'avoir une
programmation à la fois diversifiée de
qualité à la fois aussi classique et
moderne et qui s'adresse à tous les
publics
donc nous avons en particulier beaucoup
de théâtre pour commencer il ya des
comédies très légère comme par exemple
éveil du chameau et avec aure atika et
parmi les dates à retenir celle du 7
octobre avec un tram et un tramway nommé
désir et un certain francis lalanne
regarder un tramway nommé désir de
changer pour un autre des cimetières et
le descendre dire le pull noir
[Musique]
mata lima et tous les rendez-vous et
bien d'autres encore sont à retrouver
sur le site internet de kiosques pour
les programmations du prise miles en
cours et de scarabée à la verrière je
vous donne rendez vous en septembre pour
le découvrir les 7 8 culture est
maintenant terminée c'était le dernier
numéro de cette saison j'espère que ça
ait pris autant de plaisir que moi à
découvrir les acteurs qui font vivre la
culture sur 50 ans les villes dans les
temps
[Musique]